bref c'est la carte postale par
excellence au canada
la destination la plus populaire dans le
somptueux décor des rocheuses au pied
des montagnes le village grouille
d'activités en cette semaine de relâche
scolaire en alberta une scène achalandé
qu'on avait pas vu depuis des mois une
répétition générale avant un été qu'on
souhaite ici occupée
l'association touristique locale fait
preuve d'un optimisme prudent vu de sa
saison la plus importante si les
affaires devraient être bonnes ni
commerçants nouveau de l'époque ça se
fasse au détriment de la santé publique
pour uniformiser les règles et assurer
la sécurité de tous
le port du masque est obligatoire même à
l'extérieur dans les rues commerçantes à
masquer ou pas les touristes de partout
au canada sont toujours aussi charmant
nous sommes des menthol et c'est une
belle place
le chef stéphane prévôt vient tout juste
d'ouvrir un deuxième restaurant
même sans l'apport important des
touristes étrangers il s'attend lui
aussi à un bon été grâce aux touristes
canadiens incroyable toute la population
le pays
on s'attend ce qui est du québécois par
exemple qui vient de cet été mais
certains défis restent à l'aube d'une
reprise
la ville vit uniquement du tourisme et
après des mises à pied massives l'an
dernier plusieurs travailleurs ou kitty
le milieu pour de bon je me concerne
dans une position plus faciles que
d'autres
c'est évident que pour d'autres d'autres
endroits d'autres restos c'est plus
difficile de trouver du personnel
mais bon c'est plus qu'un centre ville
très achalandé c'est d'abord et avant
tout le parc national le plus populaire
au canada et des visiteurs devront
planifier leurs vacances
en conséquent cet été les amateurs de
plein air devrait prendre d'assaut les
sentiers les terrains de camping encore
cette année je pense que c'est vraiment
ça c'est planifié pour un séjour en as
tu réussi mieux vaut faire ses
réservations tôt et bien connaître
toutes les activités disponibles avant
d'arriver mais aussi d'avoir plus qu'une
option parce que si vous arrivez là de
stationnement est remplie d'avoir
quelque part d'autre pour aller pour en
visiter le site est exceptionnel et
parcs canada demande au million de
visiteurs qui viendront cet été dont
prendre soin des pensées avec respect
respect pour cet endroit respect pour la
nature respect pour les terrains la
faune mais aussi respect pour les autres
visiteurs et et nos employés avec la
queue vie de l'été 2021 sera encore loin
de la normale bélie rocheuses elles sont
toujours aussi populaires ici mathieu
gaye et radio canada banff